-In your early --
-I can hear
the cameramen breathing.
[ Laughter ]
-In your early days on stage,
did you ever have
audiences this light?
-Oh, my Lord.
I did an off-Broadway play
where, yeah, there were
more people on stage
than in the audience.
And I remember the director said
to us at one point,
"You know what I think
the problem is?
I think the lights
are too bright."
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Yes.
That's the problem.
They can see the play."
[ Laughter ]
Well, Seth, you're the only one
I get out of my sweatpants for,
and I mean that
in the nicest way.
-I really appreciate it.
-Not the mention
the nominal appearance fee.
-Right, but it's not nothing,
in this day and age.
-I'll tell you.
-There was a real dark spot
there for Broadway, and then,
last night, a lot of openings.
-I know.
-Were you out and about?
Did you go see anything?
Did you talk to friends
who are on stage?
-[ Laughs ]
-Who are you talking to,
Kristen Chenoweth?
[ Laughter ]
No, I wasn't "out and about."
No.
I don't -- No.
I'm not going into a theater
with 1,200 people.
Are you nuts?
[ Laughter ]
Who knows where they've been?
I wish you all a lot of luck
with that Broadway thing.
[ Laughter ]
No.
I heard -- yes,
a lot of shows are opening,
and I hear some of them,
they're selling very well.
-Good.
-And, look, everyone should be
cautiously optimistic.
-It would be nice.
I think those are
the perfect combination of words
for how we should be
moving forward.
-Well, you know,
because we have to be aware
that there's the delta variant,
now the mu.
-Yeah.
-The mu, which is not only
respiratory, but, you know,
there's lactating involved.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks.
Can you run around the room
and make it sound like a group?
[ Laughter ]
-This, by the way,
is as hot as it's been.
[ Laughter ]
We'll send you tapes
of some other guests.
You'll be like,
"Oh, I murdered."
-Yes.
-You did --
-Started Wally's comedy career.
-Yeah, and now Wally complains
when he's not in the show
for a week.
-I know.
-Yeah.
-Well, it's gone to his head.
Well, you know.
You've worked with divas.
[ Laughter ]
-I sure have.
-You were between a couple,
Marty and Steve, in the clip.
-Oh, those two.
-Right.
-Those two
and their shenanigans.
You know,
someone was asking me --
They said,
what was the energy like?
And I said, you know,
they're like two 20-year-olds.
You know --
Okay, maybe 30.
30-year-olds.
Two tired 30-year-olds.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Two 40-year-olds on vacation.
[ Laughter ]
Let's put it that way.
No, they are -- you know, I've
known them both a long time.
And, you know, they're at
that point in their lives where,
you know,
they're bona fide geniuses.
-Yeah.
-They have nothing to prove.
They just want to show up
together and have fun
and do good work
and make millions of dollars.
[ Laughter ]
-That's always been a really
important thing for them.
-And it seems to be working.
No, they're --
No, they were --
they set the tone
for the whole set, and you know,
they're so gracious and kind
and appreciative
of all the guest stars.
-Yeah, it's a really nice thing
about them.
And they do --
I've always said about them,
they put so much work into it,
to make it look effortless.
-Yes.
Oh, totally!
Yeah, no, they both --
Especially when they --
when they do talk shows,
it's like they're
gonna host the Oscars.
They prepare.
I myself usually prepare a lot.
You know,
this was a last-minute booking.
-It is.
You bailed us out.
-Who fell out, Lizzo?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Lizzo fell out,
and you thought --
and she suggested you.
[ Laughter ]
-"Who's like Lizzo?
Call Nathan lane.
We know
he's definitely available."
[ Laughter ]
Does he know the words
to "Truth Hurts"?
For the kids.
I do one for you,
one for the kids.
[ Laughter ]
-I want to pitch you a Broadway
musical that I'm working on,
and I think there's
a really good part for you.
-"Cicada Cicada."
-Well, the whole town is abuzz.
[ Laughter ]
Literally.
With "Cicada Cicada," you know.
[ Laughter ]
-You just made the poster,
"Cicada Cicada --
The whole town is abuzz."
[ Laughter ]
Look, if you don't get the part,
and I think
you're gonna get it --
-What do you mean, "if"?
-I'm just saying --
-What do you mean, if?
-I think you're gonna get it.
But, at the very least,
you have the tagline.
-I don't have to audition, do I?
-No, I don't think you do.
-Because I can't audition.
-No, this is --
We did hear it was offer only.
-Yeah.
-And as soon as Lizzo said no,
we were like,
"You know who we're gonna get?"
[ Laughter ]
-Lizzo.
-So, can I just talk through
the plot real quick?
And you tell me,
as someone who's
a sort of Broadway pro --
-Well, from what I hear of
the plot, it has to be quick.
[ Laughter ]
-Great.
-Yeah, go ahead.
-All right, so a Cicada is,
you know, hatched.
-Yes.
-Played by Christine Baranski,
who is a very soft yes.
[ Laughter ]
-She's an old friend of mine.
She will definitely do it.
-Okay, great.
-We're working together
on "The Gilded Age" for HBO.
-Oh, fantastic.
I'm very excited about that.
-She'll definitely do it.
-Okay. So we got Baranski
is a cicada...
-A cicada.
-...who loves Broadway,
born somewhere in Georgia
or South Carolina,
wherever cicadas are.
-So a gay cicada.
-Well, yeah, a very gay cicada
comes to New York City.
So excited, but is unaware about
their very short life span.
This is the tragedy inherent
in the play.
And it all takes place
during the pandemic.
And --
-I'm --
I'm not Bill Nye
the Science Guy.
What is their life span?
-17 days.
-I've also done
very little research.
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
Their life span is 17 days?
-In the play,
it's definitely 17 days.
-Wow.
-There's a cockroach
in the play.
-Always. That sounds
like a good part for me.
-Harvey Fierstein is gonna
play the cockroach.
-Oh, Jesus, him.
-Sorry.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-So, there's the cockroach,
and the cockroach befriends
the cicada --
-What's his life span?
[ Laughter ]
-Harvey?
Well, no, so that's the --
-The cockroach,
he can live forever.
-Sure.
-All right.
-Anyway, so the cockroach
realizes his friend the cicada
is gonna pass away
before Broadway reopens
'cause it takes place
during the pandemic,
and Broadway is closed.
The cockroach happens to live in
a very famous Broadway --
-Is the cockroach an old friend
of the cicada's?
-No, they meet in New York.
She's, like, new off the bus.
-Only 17 days.
-Yeah.
-So they meet?
-Yeah, that kind of like
"cricket in Times Square"
type meeting.
-Okay.
-You know what
I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-So anyway --
The cockroach happens to live
in the apartment
of a very famous Broadway star.
-Yeah.
-Nathan Lane.
-The cockroach in my apartment?
-Yes.
-Well, what does that
say about me personally?
[ Laughter ]
That I don't keep a clean house?
-You're spinning too much.
It's not.
The cockroach makes a --
-That sounded
right out of the shtetl.
[ Laughter ]
"You think
I don't keep a clean house?"
[ Laughter ]
So, well --
So I have a cockroach.
-You have a cockroach, and the
cockroach makes a deal with you.
-Yeah.
-"I will move out of your home."
-"I'd like to make
a deal with you."
-See? Very good.
You can be the understudy.
On the nights where Harvey's
sick, you can do both parts.
-Thanks a lot.
He'd love that.
[ Laughter ]
-So you -- he convinces you...
-Yeah.
-...to do a one-man show
for his friend the cicada
before she dies.
-Called "Cicada Cicada"?
-No, that play
is called "Cicada Cicada."
We can call it whatever we want
in the body of the show.
-Oh.
-But that's how --
it would be that you, then,
are the one-man Broadway show.
-Called "17 Days."
-"17 Days," yeah.
And I think
it'll be really good.
-But that's it, there's just
three people in this musical?
-Well, there's other characters.
Like, a lot of The Mets
are gonna be in it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, 'cause what else
are they doing?
-But there's --
Well, here's the thing.
The Mets are really bad
when the play starts.
-Well, that comes
as no surprise.
-With each of the 17 days,
The Mets keep winning.
-Oh, oh!
-And the cockroach, at the end,
has to decide if he's gonna --
-Is this set in '69?
-No, it's set in modern times.
Which is why --
Well, it's kind of a fictional
role, because The Mets do well.
[ Laughter ]
And then --
-Well, they won that one --
Wasn't it '69?
-'86 they won again.
-Yeah, yeah.
-We're a couple sports guys.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Anyway, the cockroach --
-I think I hurt myself.
[ Laughter ]
-The cockroach
has to make a choice --
"Do I go to this Mets game..."
-Right.
-"...or do I go to this
one-man -- the chance to see
my friend the cicada
see Broadway on her --"
And at the end of your show,
the cockroach gives
a standing ovation,
but the cicada doesn't.
You know why?
-Why?
-Chk! It died.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-This has a tragic ending.
-It's really tragic.
-[ Laughs ] This is --
-I think everybody thinks
it's gonna be a comedy,
and that's where we get them
at the end.
-You know, like, you know,
when you take improv classes,
you know, "Yes and..."
-Yeah.
-I think this is a great idea.
[ Laughter ]
And I just need to speak
to a few people about it.
You know, Sondheim.
-Well, we'd love
to get Sondheim.
-Would you like to get Sondheim?
-Yeah.
This is going to be
the Stephen, not Gary, right?
I've been stuck with Gary.
[ Laughter ]
If I get stuck with
Gary Sondheim one more time...
-Gary stinks,
but Steve is really good.
I would -- I would --
I certainly would sign on
if you'll have me.
-Yes, great.
All right, so I got you,
soft yes on Baranski.
You work on her,
and then Fierstein.
-Harvey Fierstein.
Have you talked to him?
-I haven't talked to him yet.
-Yeah.
-And then, The Mets,
and we're good.
-"Only Murders in the Building"
is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back.
-This is the most
I've ever seen you talk
on this show.
-Well, thanks.
I'm so overwhelmed.
-Wow.
Very exciting.
-We're gonna win a Tony.
-Oh, yeah.
-We'll be right back
with B.J. Novak.
-It's not as exciting
as you think.